When are we getting
rid of that bike?
We're going to
get rid of it today.
We have to get rid
of the bike today.
[inaudible]
Frankie and I are hauling the
Indian four cylinder project
we bought from Zane in Oregon,
because I have a friend named
Bobby Green that
owns Old Crow Speed
Shop that's going to buy it.
I paid 20 grand for the bike.
I have to have the
handlebars fixed, that big
weld on the left hand side.
There were some repairs I
needed to do on the frame.
Ben got all of that
stuff done for a grand.
That's $21,000.
All right, then I
couldn't find a gas tank.
Everybody I called were
laughing, going good luck,
stand in line, you're
never going to find it.
So I got a repop gas tank.
That was $800.
$21,800.
And then I had to find a
front fender because, remember,
the front fender was hacked off.
- Hacked off, right.
I finally found a front
fender that matches it,
patina-wise, for $1,000.
OK, so that's $22,800.
What I told Bobby on
the bike was 30 grand.
And he was all over it?
Yeah, because the baby
fours are hard to find, man.
I know they are.
Now Bobby Green is
just a name to me.
I've heard about him.
He's a hot rod specialist.
Bobby Green is like the Marlon
Brando of hot rods out here,
dude.
He races the
Bonneville Salt Flats.
Remember, like,
12 years ago when
we found that 1939
Woody that somebody
made into a pickup truck?
Yeah it had the chicken
on the side of it?
Yeah, OK.
Bobby's the guy that bought it.
OK.
He's into period patina.
That's the way he builds stuff.
- OK.
Everything he does.
Even his car hauler is period.
- Wow.
- I know.
I mean, his
attention to detail--
[inaudible]
--is a crazy cool way.
Wait until you see
the cars he builds.
You're going to freak.
I'm ready, dude.
It's going to be
code brown for you.
All right, here, where
this old truck is.
- OK.
- See what I mean?
Look at it.
- Oh, yeah.
I'm seeing what you're saying.
That's what I'm saying.
All right.
Look at that car hauler.
I can tell I already
like this place.
It's going to be
nice to have $30,000
cash for the rest of our trip.
Check that.
That's nice.
Wait until you see the
inside of this place.
Bobby!
Hey!
The Iowa boys are here.
BOBBY GREEN: You made it.
This place has
old school stuff.
It's got Harleys sitting
around, Indians sitting around.
It's like stepping back in time.
- Good to see you, man.
- Good to see you.
How are you doing, man.
- I'm doing well.
- My name's Frank.
- Frank?
Good to meet you.
I've heard a lot of
good things about you.
I'm a designer.
I restore old buildings.
I'm in the bar business.
So I kind of do with cars
what I do in my real life
with buildings and
bars and restaurants--
I just love saving something
old, bringing it back to life,
and sharing it with everybody.
- There it is.
- There she is.
Wow.
- This is it.
Gorgeous.
I know that I'm never going
to get to this Indian project,
and Bobby is the guy to take
it across the finish line.
It went from Oregon
to Iowa to California.
Wow, really?
It's got a lot of miles on it.
Hopefully it will
have a lot more.
I'm really excited
about this new bike.
I've been wanting
an early 4 cylinder
Indian for a long, long time.
They're so beautiful.
The way the tank is inside
the frame, is exposed.
This frame is in
really good shape.
I know.
These early four
cylinders are hard to find
and they're expensive.
So this is kind of
the only way I'm
really going to
get into one, you
know, one that needs some work.
Because I couldn't go just
pay, like, for a restored one.
You know, I wouldn't do it.
To me, this being built and
ready to go is the key thing.
Because that's 15, 20
grand to build the motor.
That's what he said.
His dad had like $12,000 to
$15,000 in the engine on it.
Easy.
They're hard to build.
Very few guys do it.
Now will you
sweaty up the motor,
or you'll leave
it the way it is?
Well I think that, you know,
once you start riding these,
they get sweaty quick.
- OK.
You know, they're spitting
out oil here and there.
[interposing voices]
Some people would
look at it and be like,
what are you going to paint it?
What color are you
going to paint it?
But, like, no, no
this is perfect.
The character of it
is perfect, you know?
I might do some
custom stuff to it,
and I'll leave it
sweaty and raw,
and just do little
things that make it pop.
So in the end, when
this bike's on the road,
it's going to be way
more me than some bike
restored by some other guy.
It's unbelievable.